there are certain things that I kind of
wanted to I thought were important to
happen and I thought was important that
that there was that that an electric
vehicle happened that there was a
success in the electric vehicle arena
because the the incumbent companies were
convinced that it was not possible to
create a electric car that looked good
had rained a good range performance and
so forth and that even if you did make
such a car it would not sell yeah
because people had this love of gasoline
and so we had to show that it was
possible to create a compelling electric
car long range good-looking you know all
those things that was a Tesla Roadster
and if you created if if you made such a
thing people would buy it I mean I think
the sort of fundamental good that Tesla
can accomplish is acceleration of the
inevitable which is electric
transportation I think there's a lot of
value to accelerating even though I
think it's somewhat of in Ewa table
it's about this value to accelerating it
to minimize the the the environmental
and economic damage that would otherwise
occur mm-hmm so you know it's better if
if we transit transition to sustainable
transport ten years or maybe twenty
years sooner than might otherwise be the
case and I think the Tesla's effect has
been much greater than the cars that
made that it's made internally because
when we announced the Tesla Roadster
then Bob Lutz who was by she ordered GM
at the time saw our press release and
said if if a small company in California
can do it then then so can jam he took
it to his engineers who told him that
that you couldn't build an electric car
and told him that they needed to get
going that's what got the ball rolling
and that in tune got Nissan to do the
leaf and so it's kind of got the gut
things going so now and ultimately it's
like it's what we induce other companies
to do that will have a greater impact in
the cars we make ourselves